what's going on guys this is rob and we
are covering extreme carnage which is a
story that you guys have been screaming
at me to cover no pun intended
but you guys been yelling at me to cover
this uh and honestly i was kind of
waiting until we got around to the
release of the venom uh venom 2 film now
this story is eight issues long so we're
going to split it in half so we're going
to cover the first half here then the
second half probably later on today so
the whole thing behind this is this is
really kind of a follow-up to the king
in black it really does involve carnage
but it also involves the symbiotes of
the life foundation we'll kind of
explain that a little bit once we get
into it uh but one of the first things
that happens here is it basically shows
us that the carnage symbiote at least a
piece of it is still alive and well now
the carnage symbiote in and of itself is
kind of a threat to a degree what made
the carnage symbiote so insane and
dangerous was its bonding to cletus
cassidy but cletus cassidy's gone with
this carnage symbiote there what it
actually ends up doing is there's a
couple things going on the first is you
have a kind of father and son duo right
you've got peter crane and arthur crane
and peter crane's basically a senator
trying to make his bones make a name for
himself when it comes to the presidency
and one of the things you guys are aware
of when it comes to politics is that
usually politicians they kind of their
their job is to tell you what you want
to hear so you'll elect them and then
when they get into office they execute
whatever previously established agenda
they had in mind you know before they
ever ran for office in the first place
um but the other part of this is that
you have the carnage symbiote that bonds
itself to a fish and then using that
fish it bonds itself to a great white
shark which by the way just looks
horrifying right just a great white
shark with the current symbiote just
looks absolutely terrifying but this
shark quite literally lunges on board a
somali pirate ship and ends up bonding
itself to one of the somali pirates and
then in turn all these somali pirates
are killed and then it bonds itself to
another guy and then it leaves right so
literally it's a chain reaction kind of
thing now one of the things that i do
want to specify here this is one of the
things that makes the semis themselves
so incredibly versatile i wouldn't
really say dangerous so much as
versatile as most of you guys know they
do have sentience they can think for
themselves but if a symbiote is dead set
on being returned to a host it'll start
jumping through different bodies to get
to that point right everybody and
everything can serve as a means for
symbiote to travel and so what you end
up doing is kind of transitioning back
to this uh this this kind of campaign
rally by uh peter crane where he
basically kind of goes on this this
speech about how the different things
that have happened in recent years right
the idea of these symbiotes kind of
running awry the king in black different
things like that right the whole empire
event which we didn't cover because that
story sucks like all these different
things that are going on that they all
kind of tie into this idea that humanity
is essentially under threat from like an
extraterrestrial race now the reality of
this is that's not really the case but
as a politician his job is to feed on
the fears and the the uncertainty of the
general public in order to get them to
elect him into office right because
nothing is more effective than fear but
one of the revelations he throws out
here is that we all have to take action
right something has to be done what are
we going to do about these tony starks
these charles xaviers anybody who
harbors aliens and so on and so what he
says is that he's announcing a
partnership with the newly reorganized
and refocused friends of humanity now as
soon as that was revealed i was like
what the friends of humanity okay so
here's the thing friends of humanity is
old school right like unless you're an
old school x-men fan you will have no
idea who the friends of humanity are
right the friends of humanity the right
right though that kind of a thing these
were basically groups specifically the
friends of humanity was basically a
group that was rooted in what was in
effect bigotry right these guys hated
anybody who was a mutant that was not a
baseline human and they would launch
attacks they would do all kinds of stuff
right anybody who wasn't like them or
anybody who didn't believe what they
believed they would go after now one of
the big things about this is that it was
initially launched by a guy named
graydon creed and graydon creed was
actually the non-powered son of mystique
and sabertooth and it was kind of crazy
because mystique literally banged saber
tooth without saber tooth knowing that
she was a mutant and then in turn she
gave birth to creed and then put him up
for adoption but he had this just
staunch anti-mutant uh perception now
when it all came to a head that's when
friends of humanity began to really lose
credibility super fast and for the most
part it's been a joke for years but to
see the friends of humanity coming back
is nuts i absolutely i loved the friends
of humanity as a concept but one of the
things that peter crane is doing here is
basically introducing something called
the birthright act basically saying that
those individuals who are not born on
earth cannot be here on earth right they
have to kind of be pushed away and
forced to leave and it's one of the
things that he kind of addresses right
he's like in this world that we live in
and this political climate that we live
in you have those individuals out there
who are basically nothing more than like
john turturro and miller's crossing when
he was begging for his life right that's
all they are right like they have no
real teeth there's nothing they can
really do which is you have to look into
your heart and and if it can't be done
with a strongly worded letter they just
don't worry about it right and then you
have people who actually get things done
and peter crane is one of those guys who
sees himself as somebody who gets things
done he's like while they're out there
doing their little protests and writing
their strongly worded letters and hoping
people look into their hearts and
realize that their heart is three sizes
too small you know we're gonna actually
get stuff done and so that's one of the
things that makes them such a such a
menace here or such a threat here is
because following that of course they
end up going into their their you know
their kind of meeting place and it's
like well you know it all kind of went
pretty well you know and that kind of a
thing you know your stream went fine the
normal kind of rhythm reward that you
see when it comes to politics right
making sure that the the message
resonates with the audience the biggest
problem they have here is they're still
part of like they're so really attached
to a fringe audience because most people
in the general public don't really
consider the events of king and black to
be like a global threat right the
symbiotes are a global threat because it
was basically taken care of and so what
he needs to do is kind of expand his
message out to the larger general public
and it's going to be kind of crazy
because this gets instigated in one of
the most insane ways ever but what we
end up doing here is actually switching
over to a guy by the name of dr miller
now dr miller was the guy who was on the
somali pirate ship who was attacked by
the carnage symbiote which as we
basically know now the symbiotes bonded
to him the crazy thing about this is
that as his chauffeur is kind of looking
through his phone he gets a text message
from a guy named dr miller and this is
kind of like what and then like as soon
as that happens right you know carnage
realizes the jig is up and like takes
his kid out right just like just
completely consumes and destroys this
kid now switch over to probably one of
the most important characters of the
entire story flash thompson now here's
the thing those of you guys who never
saw our videos or really any of our
venom videos flash thompson of course as
most of you guys know was the bully of
peter parker when he was in high school
the first real host of the venom
symbiote was eddie brock later on after
flash thompson lost his legs in wartime
conflict the symbiote was kind of
restructured and then bonded to him and
he basically became agent venom and had
what really is one of the most
celebrated venom runs in the history of
marvel comics right people love agent
venom or agent venom was a really really
cool story and i think we covered a
little bit of it and we should probably
cover the rest i don't know if you guys
are interested in seeing that or not but
the the important thing here is that uh
flash thompson had basically died but
during the events of king and black he
was brought back and then he was bonded
to the anti-anti-venom suit and so
basically it's a symbiote suit that can
actually cure people right but it was
just kind of a way to bring flash
thompson back and make him into somebody
else which is really really cool but the
crazy thing about this is flash thompson
is working as a charity worker now right
i mean he's basically helping to unload
boxes things like that you know to
charity organizations and so on and so
forth with a friend of his name hank
when suddenly he's met by the arrival of
carnage now carter does not actually
show up to flash thompson instead what
he does he takes the consciousness of
flash thompson and brings it to carnage
himself so what carnage has basically
learned to do here is exactly what null
the symbiote god learned to do which was
basically take people's consciousness
and bring them to him and so what he
does is he communicates with flash
thompson like i'm not dead man you know
clears cassidy's dead but i the carnage
symbiote and still very much alive and
well and you have to rejoin me right you
have to come back you've got to be part
of our of my symbiote hive right that
carnage is basically trying to grab all
these different symbiotes and
consolidate them back under himself now
without null there and presumably
without venom being aware of what's
going on here this would make carnage a
highly dangerous threat how he would
stand against somebody like venom in his
current form kind of being like a
universal force we don't fully know what
we do know is that flash is like not a
chance right and is able to overcome the
carnage symbiote this is one of the big
kickers about this right when carnage
mentally possesses a person he in turn
controls their body and that's why when
flash thompson's mind is taken by
carnage carnage is able to control the
body or the symbiote of flash thompson
and he almost kills hank but but you
know flash is able to basically regain
his sanity or regain his mind long
enough to where he's able to stop
himself and then basically take off only
to bump into iron man now when he meets
up with iron man here this is kind of
the cool thing iron man of course kind
of shows the the symbiote hybrid armor
that he'd been building for a little
while which of course we were already
aware of but two he's been tracking
symbiote activity and basically his it's
kind of like look carnage just is back
right cleo's cassidy's dead but carnage
is back and it's seemingly going to try
to find a new host somewhere we don't
know exactly how this is going to play
out and so what you end up having is
this again you know tony stark kind of
putting flash thompson in the direction
of peter crane and saying this guy's a
legitimate threat we don't really know
what's going on with him but one way or
another somebody needs to find out and
given your history as being like an
agent you're the person best suited to
do this and so what ends up happening
here is flash thompson actually goes to
a campaign rally of peter crane and as
that happens he suddenly met by the
voice of carnage right and the voice of
carnage kind of tries to you know
intimidate him a little bit kind of talk
to him a little bit sort of mess with
his mind you know kind of play a little
bit a few of the mind games here and
while all that's going on peter crane's
looking directly at him right and then
you have flash who turns into anti-venom
and then immediately goes after peter
crane now of course he's stopped by the
forces of peter crane but the important
thing here is that flash comes up on
this very very significant realization
where he believes the carnage symbiote
has bonded itself to peter crane and
that peter crane is basically possessed
by carnage right he's the new host which
is kind of interesting because if that
were the case right if that were
actually the case one it would explain
the motivations of peter crane in terms
of why he's doing what he's doing and
two it would give him a huge playing
field because what it would mean is that
if the birthright act goes through and
any alien race that exists out there is
forced to leave the world that means the
advanced technology or the advanced
intelligence those alien races offer
would likely be forced to go as well
which would basically clear the playing
field because if you have carnage who's
able to operate in free reign albeit in
secret he can bond himself to some
insanely powerful people he can even
spread himself we know that much just
from the events of absolute carnage
right he's able to kind of implant
himself in different people and turn
them into whatever basically copies but
servants of himself and then in turn
expand his sphere of influence across
the world i.e conquer earth seemingly in
the same way that that null the symbiote
god did right and so what you end up
doing here is you actually switch over
to alkamax right now alcomax as a lot of
you guys may or may not know is a pretty
significant organization it's more
significant in the future in like the
2099 universe where miguel o'hara
spider-man 2099 comes from than it is
here in the modern era uh but they're by
and large just like this massive
conglomeration right they're not like
roxanne where like roxon has its hand
and like every criminal act ever but but
alcomax will become that way right and
so that's the kind of lingering threat
that that alcamax poses but the other
part of this is alkamax has been engaged
in a lot of different nefarious things
creating monsters creating beings out
there some of which can be used for
military application others necessarily
not the same way but what this does is
it focuses on the character of scream
and scream of course is one of the life
foundation symbiotes now this is an
important thing that i want to discuss
here so the light foundation as most of
you guys know or may be aware from the
original venom film was basically a kind
of organization that existed out there
in order to find a way to either subdue
create or use symbiotes in some form or
fashion in mobile comics it was really
more rooted in the cold war but the
characters of riot lasher phage and
scream are the result of the life
foundation basically taking pieces of
venom and then making symbiotes out of
that right now the life foundation
symbiotes have a a somewhat tumultuous
history in marvel uh they were really
interesting during the like original
lethal protector run the biggest problem
that you have with this is that interest
in their characters waned pretty fast
and they kind of fell to the background
i'm pretty sure we have a video
explaining these guys the important
thing here is that there was a point
where they basically became hybrid but
more recently when it came to marvel
comics specifically during the king in
black is there was a girl named sadie
now sadie was a girl whose family was
basically breaking up and the idea here
is that sadie wanted to keep her family
together and so during the king and
black and absolute carnage story what
actually ended up happening here is that
the concept of hybrid the four life
foundation symbiote members had
basically bonded together into a single
symbiote and then bumped into sadie and
then ultimately went into her home and
bonded themselves to each member of her
family and then in turn they had
basically been taken over by uh by
carnage during the events of absolute
carnage and then forced to go out and
find all these other individuals out
there who have been bonded with
symbiotes over the years and who have a
kind of remnant of the symbiote itself
in the form of a codex in order to take
them and bring them to carnage by and
large this worked until they ran into
reed richards of the fantastic four from
an alternate reality and then basically
they were all defeated right then they
were split apart and they just kind of
went and did their own thing for a
little while right and so this is really
kind of the first time that you're
seeing the life foundation symbiotes
re-emerge post king and black slash
absolute carnage the only real exception
here is when it comes to scream right
she had bonded to andy benton and if
we're being honest with ourselves we're
better off doing a full-on character
explanation of andy benton just given
the the nature of how involved she is
but the long and short of this is that
she is both the host of a symbiote as
well as a person who possesses a hell
mark basically meaning that at some
future point in time she could become a
hell lord similar to mephisto i don't
know she'd really be as powerful but
nonetheless she has the ability to use
hellfire now she doesn't like being
bonded to scream but it's one of those
things where they kind of have a mutual
benefit by staying together right and so
the results of this is that as this all
goes down as soon as the scream symbiote
overhears the the kind of speech that uh
that peter crane was making to the
general public that suddenly the scream
symbiote basically starts going insane
seemingly it puts off this idea that
there was a kind of subliminal message
right it lends credence to the idea that
peter crane really is possessed by the
carnage symbiote because as peter crane
speaks is actually the carnage symbiote
who's speaking or at least that seems to
be the case and is basically sending out
a message to all the symbiotes that are
out there and because they all share a
similar dna using that as a way to in
effect hijack the symbiotes and then
force them back to him and so that's why
a kind of internal fight happens between
scream and between uh between andy
benton now in the midst of all this
carnage does exactly what he did with
flash thompson which is take the mind of
andy benton and snatch it up and whisk
it away to the quote unquote hive mind
right where carnage's carnage kind of
reigns supreme you could call it a kind
of ethereal place not physically
tangible but more or less in the mind
and that happens as carnage just kind of
takes over and communicates with scream
at the same time talking to andy and so
one of the crazy things that happens
here is that he basically kind of tells
scream andy benton never wanted to be
bonded to you right you never wanted to
be bonded to andy benton so at the end
of the day why not leave and why not
join me but ultimately andy benton
succeeds in freeing herself from screams
control the problem is doing this
requires her to invoke her hellfire and
when that happens because hellfire
injures scream scream take this as an
affront that you know carnage was right
you were never on my side right like you
were never a friend of mine like you
burned me with your hellfire and
basically she ends up burning off the
entirety of the scream symbiote itself
right like it's it's completely and
totally gone and so that's when andy's
basically just left by herself right
it's her and the scream symbiote is
completely gone now the funny thing
about this is that it reveals this
aspect of andy benton that we weren't
really aware of that where andy benton
seemed to hate being bonded to the
screams symbiote the symbiote seemed to
hate being bonded to her but they stayed
together because it was just mutually
beneficial that actually andy benton had
learned to love her symbiote right the
the symbiote that she had she'd kind of
grown attached to much of the same way
that that eddie brock had grown attached
to the venom symbiote but the important
thing here is that with andy venton just
kind of without a symbiote these guys
don't know that right that these these
kind of guardsmen are unaware of that
and they in turn go to attack her
believing she has a symbiote unto
herself and so of course where she's
able to hold her own and basically take
these guys out that what you end up
doing is switching over to phage right
now phage again another member of the
life foundation symbiotes has kind of
been free floating out there had
basically bonded itself to a dog and a
lot of that's because it did that when
it was part of the sadie family right it
bonded itself to sadie's dog and what
it's been doing is basically living
alongside a guy named cash buckman but
the cool thing here is that when the
message goes out again from peter crane
so you guys are kind of seeing this
common theme that the symbiote actually
released the dog attacks cash buckman
and basically kills him and then from
there goes forward seemingly to go after
or to locate carnage now at this point
we pick up with a guy by the name of dr
steven right now dr steven was a really
interesting character he was originally
introduced in venom 151 the importance
of dr steven is that following the
events of flash thompson as anti-venom
and going into eddie brock kind of
getting the venom symbiote back for a
period of time that what this led to was
the venom symbiote kind of becoming a
far more violent than it had been before
and so the desire of eddie brock was to
find out why this was happening and so
ultimately he ended up meeting with uh
meeting with dr steven and ultimately
one of the things that took place here
is that a conflict ensued in spider-man
792 and really the alpha issue of a
venom venom incorporated and basically
led to a couple different things one
flash thompson became anti-venom for the
very first time and two this basically
led to dr steven kind of being a
really a massive authority when it came
to the nature of symbiotes now he kind
of already was to a degree in the sense
that he was head of alkamax's
astrobiology team but his experience
with the anti-venom suit with the venom
symbiote so on and so forth has
basically kind of made him a massive
authority on it the funny thing about
this here is that when he's talking to
basically andy benton as she's being
held in place that his whole statement
is that i'm not necessarily here to
cause you problems like i'm here to try
to find a way to basically save the
scream symbiote so he's not really
villainous per se it's really more him
just kind of being here uh being used by
alcamax because of his experience with
the symbiotes and then just trying to at
the very least prevent as much suffering
as possible while he's doing his job the
problem here comes with phage which is
basically bonded itself to both the dog
and cash buckman and as it shows up here
it immediately starts going and
attacking andy benton and the reason why
is because with andy bentin basically
you know seemingly destroying scream the
way that she did that phage takes this
as a personal affront now that's one of
the things to know about the life
foundation symbiotes is that while they
are kind of being brought in as part of
carnage's hive mind they do share
something of a hive mind to themselves
right in the sense of this kind of a
shared consciousness to a degree not in
the sense that they operate under a
singular mind right and they're just
kind of facsimiles of this greater mind
but in the sense that they all kind of
know what the others doing now part of
this is because they're all basically
derived from the venom symbiote but a
lot of it's because of when they were
merged as part of hybrid and different
things like that right but at the end of
the day phage takes it as a personal
affront that that essentially andy
benton had more or less destroyed scream
and the desire of phage is to kill andy
benton for killing scream now what you
also have going on there is flash
thompson as anti-venom who basically
shows up at alcomax only to meet dr
stephen and then that's kind of the
crazy thing is he doesn't attack him
right because dr stephen had helped
flash thompson on a multitude of
occasions right and so the desire here
is to use or at least to have dr steven
help him find a way to basically save
andy benton so of course with phage
facing off against andy she's able to
hold her own to a degree the problem is
that the the hellfire of andy benton
does not affect phage the same way that
it affected scream and it's one of these
things where even phage kind of
hypothesizes and saying like i think the
reason why it affected scream is because
scream wanted to be destroyed right she
wanted to to basically be removed from
you or whatever the case happens to be
but the important thing is you basically
have flash thompson who shows up here to
aid andy benton as best he can but one
of the things that goes on is that in
this conflict phage basically impales
andy benton by quite literally punching
a hole through this chick right and so
it's kind of crazy
that seemingly this girl is killed and
that's one of the crazy things is that
each one of these symbiotes kind of has
something to offer and phage in a lot of
ways was just kind of unbridled strength
right it was just sort of nuts and so of
course you end up having these these
forces of alchemax who come showing up
here right who are supposed to contain
this whole thing and it doesn't do any
good right none of it really matters i
mean at the end of the day phages
crushes all these guys more so than that
of course flash thompson isn't
necessarily trying to kill these guys
but you know i mean if they get in the
way a few bullets kind of sprayed their
direction yeah whatever happens happens
the other important thing here is that
there's actually an elderly man who's
just kind of staying in this hospital
right he's suffering with extreme
dementia and he's basically met by the
lasher symbiote right and the lasher
symbiote bonds itself to this guy now
the crazy thing is as soon as that
happens right as soon as the lasher
symbiote bonds itself to the sky that
you kind of have two things going on at
the same time right you've got phage
who's just killing all these guys at
alcomax just just ripping all these guys
to pieces and you've got flash who's
trying to get andy benton out of there
as fast as he possibly can and then
you've got the lasher symbiote bonded to
this old man with dementia who's just
killing everybody that he can come
across right so like it's exceedingly
crazy and violent and so what is up
happening here is his carnage tries to
contact the lasher symbiote and then in
turn says like come back to me right now
lasher says no like immediately shuts
that down and says no not a chance
that's not going to happen now lasher i
would always argue is kind of the more
intelligent of the four life foundation
symbiotes but because of the fact that
it won't join his cause what carnage
does is it communicates with the mind of
the host and basically says like i can
bring your memories back right you have
dementia you're you've essentially lost
these giant chunks of your of your
history i can give those back to you
right i can give you your family back
all you have to do is come to me and so
ultimately what ends up happening is the
host actually forces the lasher symbiote
to to basically follow its will and
starts taking it to where carnage is
supposed to be the whole time the lashes
to me is like no this is that's not what
you think right like you think you're
going to go to carnage and you think
he's going to give you your memories
back but that's not going to happen
right you take him and he's going to
take me and then he's going to kill you
right that's exactly what's going to
happen now the other part of this is
that for andy benton right i mean she's
got a giant hole in her chest right like
her days are numbered
there's not a whole lot you can do here
and so with flash thompson taking her to
dr steven what you actually end up
learning here is dr steven had done
something interesting that he had taken
the anti-venom symbiote or at least a
portion of the anti-venom symbiote and
spliced this genetic structure and then
bonded it with the scream symbiote to
create a whole new symbion and then in
turn that's taken and bonded to uh to
andy benton and basically this symbiote
kind of basically says like you know
it's it is the absence of scream right
the lack of scream that is the negative
space of noise and the sound of silence
right and that's basically what it calls
itself this is a holy new symbion right
this is completely new totally
engineered this symbiote has never
existed before right so those of you
guys who are kind of curious over the
course of like marvel comics how it is
the symbiotes come into existence truth
to tell there's no former function to it
right it just happens randomly sometimes
it is the venom symbiote leaving behind
a kind of offspring in a prison cell
that's inhabited by cletus cassidy which
bonds itself to cletus and becomes
carnage and sometimes it's a person
splicing the dna of two different
symbiotes together and then creating a
wholly new one but what this symbiote is
is basically emerging between scream and
anti-venom right so it's kind of
interesting they called it silence you
think they would just call it
anti-scream but i could definitely see
why they would call it silence because
anti-scream is silence right so why not
just call it silence
and so while all that's getting on we
get this really really brief moment
which i know a lot of you guys are going
to absolutely love right because it's
one character that we've never talked
about here on comics explain but
probably the best out of all the
symbiotes out there probably the most
powerful out of all the symbiotes out
there you go to staten island right and
you've got this kid named brynn and
brynn is watching tv
and it's symbiotes like are all tv shows
this boring and mundane and brent's kind
of like i mean yeah basically like the
kids show is just boring as hell and
then they end up flipping to a station
and everything's popping off at alcomax
and then bren's like i gotta go help my
dad right and basically it's symbiote
kind of loads up and the two of them go
taking off now who is bryn brin is toxin
and toxin is amazing i absolutely love
toxin toxins like the best cement out of
all the symbiotes this dude is so op but
the important thing here
is switching back to phage right just
kind of going on this rampage though you
actually get to see the full powers of
silence on display where using its kind
of anti-venom powers combined with the
screen powers basically shuts down phage
right i mean literally just overpowers
this guy with a quickness it's done so
much so that that really silence looks
like she kind of kills the host and
that's kind of the crazy thing that's
something that you don't really see all
that often when it comes to symbiotes
another symbiote being able to basically
kill the host outright and in turn force
the symbiote to leave that host and move
on to somebody else right the symbiote
serves as a kind of protection with
these things so it's kind of wild and so
what you actually end up having here is
basically this this host for lasher
right this old man that he basically
ends up getting lasher to take him
directly to the lincoln memorial and
then as soon as that happens he's like
release me right and basically just
falls to his death and essentially dies
but his consciousness you know kind of
continues on and so seemingly his
consciousness is kind of trapped in the
in the i guess the mindscape of carnage
but of course carnage basically kills
his consciousness right so basically
this old man is officially dead and
because of this what it does is it
allows carnage to take over the last
year symbiote and then force the lasher
symbiote unto himself with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end keep an eye out for part two coming
later on today thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace